hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the distinctives of cynic
philosophy as an intentional way of
living or a philosophy as a way of life
is what we can call begging the cynics
carried a minimal amount of possessions
and went around asking people four
things it could have been for money
there's a lot of mentions of money in
the cynic Epistles that are attributed
probably falsely to karates but which
are reflective of the the cynic mindset
and philosophy and so we see a lot of
discussions about who should you beg
from how should you beg are you owed
anything how should we think about these
sorts of matters and this is quite
interesting because you know this is so
Central to not just the philosophy as a
set of practices but you could call it
the material basis for keeping that
philosophy and indeed the philosophers
alive and so there's a number of
discussions and I think one of the
places that we should start is by
looking at
several letters that are attributed to
Kratos that are are being addressed to
the Athenian people
and there's actually a very interesting
one just preceding this where he talks
about how they don't use their money
very well they run through it and they
you know should sell some of their
horses and pretend that their asses are
horses so he's talking to the Athenian
people why to the Athenian people well
this is where you're going to find quite
a few people practicing Scenic
philosophy right it's one of the main
schools that we see and so
he tells the Athenians uh don't be
amazed if diogenes saying that all
things belong to the wise man approached
you and did not ask for something but
demanded back what was do him so this is
part of the argument for why it's okay
for cynics to engage in begging they're
not really asking other people for their
stuff that just totally belongs to those
other people they're asking for
something that in a way is like common
goods or common property and so there's
going to be an argument made here with
several ideas as promises he says you're
not amazed that all things belong to God
Theos all things are literally of God
and then he says on the contrary you
admit even if someone appears to you in
a dream and orders you to sacrifice you
would sacrifice to him so if you've got
some sort of indication that the God
wants something back well you'll give it
to him and we we see this also in uh the
you know the other letter in in 27 all
things belonging to God right uh as well
so he says that when Helios begs from
you
um you don't actually say that but you
say he demands back what belongs to him
having said all things belong to God
you're not vaxxed when he demands
something of you so you're cool with
that right you also he says have another
thing that you say that all things are
common to friends to people who you know
care for each other right who are in
good relationships with each other so
all things belong to God friends have
all things in common so the conclusion
here is that all things actually belong
to the wise person and I should mention
here they're a little bit of vocabulary
so throughout these letters and their
English translation we see references to
the wise but the Greek term is actually
to spudiu not you know
um the sofos not the wise person the
sage but rather you could translate
spudia very literally as the serious
person but also as the morally upright
person the decent person
could we view this as the whys well it
would certainly be a class that would
include what we traditionally call Wise
people the The Virtuous right those who
possess practical wisdom or even wisdom
of other greater things but in a way
it's less of a
bar to reach you could say at least in
the way that it's it's used typically so
he says that all things you know we
should say belong to the wise and he
goes on a little bit further and he says
only the wise person is a friend of God
and so you know when the wise person is
asking then you shouldn't get upset or
raise a stink about it the Greek term
there is actually
halapai name which means to be difficult
about it you should just you should give
to them he's talking again to non-philos
to the Athenian people don't get upset
when this person comes along and asks
you for something a biting right they
are begging they are asking they are
giving you some sort of reason to give
something to them
and so you know in in 26 he reiterates
this heed the argument and do not be
angry again
when you're asked for three Opals by a
wise person you're giving back not what
is yours but what is actually theirs
what it is that they deserve so that's
something that's being said to
non-philosophers about how philosophers
ought to be treated they're at least
cynic philosophers
and then in section letter 17 we have
this very funny analogy that is being
developed and diogenes as being uh you
know talked about again doctors have
written about one condition of the
bowels or the guts which they say causes
indigestion so we've got an analogy
that's going to be happening here
diogenes is written about another which
he says causes hunger what what is that
one that causes hunger uh poverty right
so he's saying it's it's okay for going
around
asking people who have medical knowledge
or medical
equipment or in this case pills or other
remedies it's fine to ask them for
things it's not disgraceful to ask
doctors for medicine but it is
considered so for the latter condition
being poor and being hungry and so he
says for this reason to spy as those who
say such base and disreputable things
and beg bread as well as pills it's not
begging that is that is base it's not
begging or asking that is shameful ice
grown but rather as he says showing
yourself Unworthy of what it is that is
given and the word for unworthy there is
May oxion right oxios means having a
certain kind of value so you're asking
the doctor for remedies why are you
asking the doctor for remedies well
because you're a glutton you eat too
much right he says it's characteristic
of unscrupulous men to bag on account of
indigestion rather than hunger why
because indigestion is caused by
gluttony gastro margian that's the
actual word for gluttony which is caused
or results from wickedness
but hunger is caused by a lack of
resources Opera on which we can
translate is poverty or just being
without what you need and so in in a
certain way you're actually
less shameful asking for for food or for
money for food then you are asking for
remedies for eating too much and being a
Gourmand right there are also some
interesting discussions here
um some advice which doesn't all
completely add up about who cynics
should bag from and accept things from
and so we have three different letters
that are actually addressing this
he tells us in letter number two do not
beg the necessities of life from
everyone don't accept from everyone what
is given to you why because it's not
right
it's not just it's not in accordance
with Divine Justice that
um
virtue should be supported by Vice or
more literally nourished uh
right there to to take care of in bodily
ways to attend to so who should you take
from then he says well then you should
beg only from those people and accept
gifts only from those people who have
been initiated into philosophy and he
uses the word philosophia right there in
a broad sense not not meaning that
people who've taken a class in
philosophy but people who are living a
you know a decent thoughtful intentional
way of organizing their their life right
so go to those people and ask them for
stuff and he says then it will be
possible for you to demand back watch
but what belongs to you again we see
this idea of when you're begging you're
not really asking somebody to put
themselves out and give you something
that you have no
um right to you're not worthy of at all
you're asking for something back from
them and he says you won't be a you
won't appear to be begging for what is
belonging to or what derives to from
another
that which belongs to another person so
that's an interesting idea a little bit
later on in letter 22 which is a little
bit further developing this he's talking
to metricles one of his students the
brother of hipparchia the woman that
he's actually married to we don't know
if that's supposed to be the case at
this time so he says don't beg from
everybody
but only from the Worthy two's axios and
again we see this notion of worthiness
or value right
um but how far does this extend well
when we look at the further
clarifications maybe you don't have to
be that worthy to to be begged from he
says don't take the same amount from
everyone except a trioble that's a a
small amount from The Prudent
those who have so frostedness uh you
know or those who can run their Affairs
right and prudent here maybe we should
translate this as temperate those who
can keep their appetites in check right
so just accept a small bit from them but
Amina From spendthrus Now Amina is a
large amount of money so why would you
if if you're supposed to take only from
those those who are worthy why would you
take a huge amount of money from one
person and just a little bit from
somebody who's better than them
well there's a very practical reason
that's given here
um you cannot receive anything from them
as you can from The Prudent again right
because they squander their money
recklessly so if they want to give you a
big uh payout take it because it's
probably not going to happen again we
could probably say this about other
people as well those who are going to
give you you know a large amount of
money but they're not really good people
uh they're just doing it maybe out of a
sense of guilt or because they had a
windfall or something like that you're
probably not going to see them doing
that a second time so you may as well
take it it doesn't say what you're going
to do with the money maybe the
assumption is that you as the cynic you
know you don't actually carry around a
bank or anything maybe you would spread
it around the community as well finally
in letter 36 we get another discussion
about who we ought to be taking money
from
and he says diogenes declare that not
only should those who beg for silver
have these cynic Fitness to be a beggar
to go out and ask people for that but on
the other side those two who give should
have he says the compassion of the wise
person now this is again very
interesting we're seeing the spudios
here so the wise is is an okay
translation decent people people who are
devoted to Virtue but don't necessarily
have it yet right but this is a very
interesting thing to say the wise person
feels compassion they're motivated by
that the Greek word here is uh electicon
and that means motivated by Compassion
or pity is another way of translating it
Leos in in Greek so he says since you
know this don't approach and beg from
everyone you won't receive anything from
them but beg only from the wise person
we can say that this person and none of
the others is actually called happy
there's there's eudaimonia or eudaimona
for them where there isn't for others so
they're more likely to because they are
actually happy living a good life a good
life from a philosophical point of view
they're going to be more generous with
their money because they realize that
the money isn't really that important
and that it should be shared with other
people so we're getting a bit of
is a contradictory advice
possibly there's certainly a tension
there there's something that's being
developed about who you should in fact
take things from what uh spirit you
should be begging in who you're likely
to get things from and so this is uh
some very interesting information here
that is being provided sort of after the
fact we don't think that these letters
are actually bi karates but they are
reflective of the cynic tradition and
the mindset behind it